[Musik]
dies ist der pilatus in luzern in der
schweiz vor über 100 jahren entwickelten
wagemutiger unternehmer revolutionäre
technologie für eine zahnradbahn auf den
gipfel des berges
noch heute ist sie die schnellste bahn
ihrer art der welt der aufstieg dauerte
zu fuß und auf lastesel meinen tag nun
war ermöglicht in weniger als 40 minuten
dies machte den pilatus weltberühmt
etwas ähnliches spielt sich nun erneut
ab wintek unternehmer entwickeln neue
technologie und software um banken
dienstleistungen einfacher günstiger und
bequemer zu machen
zusammen mit den schweizer banken
möchten sie den finanzplatz ins digitale
zeitalter bringen
ich bin schweizer und unternehmer meinen
ersten start up gründete ich 1996 in der
schweiz und danach weitere firmen in
amerika und japan
ich habe bücher über finance und
unternehmertum geschrieben dass banken
land schweiz und finn tag den sich
offensichtlich an es gibt aber auch
andere voraussetzungen hier als im
ausland
um einen besseren überblick über winter
in der schweiz zu erhalten
besuchte ich unternehmer investoren
bankiers und politiker mit ihnen sprach
ich über ihre erfahrungen heraus
forderungen und wünsche für finn tech
made in switzerland
[Musik]
die wahl ist noch lief simone kraft
wissen dass man technologie jetzt kann
grün bringenden tat ist ob die
finanzwelt ihnen bringe seehofer
tragwerke ich bin hat müsse nicht erst
abwarten was gibts eigentlich auf der
technologischen und wir haben
cross of doing things are used the fact
that can be used to face und uci world
space gt2 betrachtet sein ich finde es
war engagiert und es ist sehr stark
sagte self service aus der beatles sei
zwar gering fortbestehende
finanzdienstleister der schrei betracht
es gab wesentlich wieder ein start zum
digitalisierung und weniger dass man
vorne geht sondern um das ganz große
thema um wie gesagt wertschöpfungskette
von der zukunft des von den finanzämtern
strecken weil man jetzt überall hakt
jetzt einfach dass das ist immer noch
aktiv
aber das ist einfach also vielleicht
auch mit druck auf den knopf das darf
sich um bestätigte und steaks und das
ganze ist prozesse und ich glaube sehr
viel mehr vor der bank leichte bis zum
schluss da unterstellt ist und am
schluss einfach 100 ist sehr sehr viel
einfach wie könnten kunden direkt die
dienstleistung zur verfügung stelle
und das erstaunlichste große unterschied
es ist nicht so dass man neue business
modelle kreiert und wohnungsbau 16 17
jahren als trainer vorstellen dass
durchaus gesehen aber der kunde ist
könig sie will einfach die mittel nicht
zur verfügung hat zum verteilen
profitieren
convenience ist
wo der hund wird und dass eben auch von
der breiten spektrum richtig gar nicht
so spektakulär aber ich glaube wenn man
eine beschrieben hätten optimieren
dann hätte es nicht spektakulär
empfunden hat beschrieb ich sehe aber
muss man sagen es ist einfach irgendwie
medienunternehmens digitalisierung also
bank sich interessieren wesentlich
einfacher technologie geht so weit dass
das ist alles so richtig effizienz
optimiert werden und aus wie effektiv
der effektivität wird wird optimiert die
geschichte von der ökonomie
das wird auch im stark regulierten
finanzmarkt natürlich hat finanzkrise
die ganze szene nimmt verbraucht auf der
andere seite primera wieder viel
gutmachen
einfach wieder der mensch ist sand
umsätze und überlegt wie ich immer
technologie benutzt um das finanzwesen
finanzmarkt wieder zum bäcker fährt von
der lügt und wann das schaffe dann haben
wir aus ziel erreicht und dann machen
wir aber viel geld
dann macht wirklich spaß wie den hummer
bis leistungsband die korrektur kommen
ministerin produzieren mit dem aber auch
trug spiele und die chance aus marbach
spiele und die freude am gestalten
ich glaube das ist das wo man noch
vermisst mehrfach gelogen hat das
opportunität also mich selbst ganz
sicher chancen dann ist ganz sicher so
ja natürlich
opera aber grundsätzlich ist das für uns
ist das eine tolle chance jetzt die
letzten paar jahren hat das ja
eigentlich sehr sehr gut funktioniert
dass man wirklich gesagt hat man selbst
das zentrum neue technologien mit seinem
hund crossgate firmenrekord und dass man
sei also das hat eigentlich sehr sehr
gut funktioniert jetzt nicht wieso man
der weiter beschritten richtiger die im
blut auf sie ein dass man finance lab
foto menschen verbessere dann braucht es
nicht
das konzeptionelle hilfs wissenschaft
vor economy wer der verein hat sich zum
risiko photomatix reduzieren
zum ertrag für die altersvorsorge zu
verbessern hat man mir wenn man mir
sieht man wie vor zweiter weltkrieg in
der industrie so viel chance jetzt
finanzindustrie und mit acht der
finanzindustrie ist die beste zeit der
industrie als chance nutzen
wien eigentlich sie im studium das heißt
die letzte serie unter versicherung was
wir bei knipp gemacht haben wieder den
es noch ich hatten irgendeine ahnung von
versicherung
wir sind eigentlich so gestaltet dass
wir gesagt haben wir denken knapp aus
kundensicht und das war glaube ich am
ende dann das auch das erfolgsgeheimnis
für unsere idee weil wir einfach nicht
diese versicherungs denke auch von den
prozessen herten und wie man das schon
immer gemacht hat sondern wir haben
digitales wissen auf die
versicherungswelt angewendet beschrieb
von traditioneller bank den preis noch
an der dann in find ick mal dienen ist
ein schnitt sondern große schritt sie
will find sich vereinen
aber spannend ist wer kann ich mit
technologie mich differenzieren mehrheit
des jahrhunderts um bekommt also mein
christoph das produkt kaufen twist wir
und zeigt jetzt der höhe das risiko
dabei mache die gesellschaft nur für das
produkt investor gefunden wo sie vision
und das team um glauben und händen
gemeinsam das ganze noch bauten wie auch
in den letzten zweieinhalb jahre sich
unter basis mehr als verzehnfacht
ich bin so oft mit einem riesen strahlen
ins büro gegangen weil ich einfach so
erfüllt war von endorphinen ja aber
andererseits wenn man als gründer und
als unternehmer in so was drin ist man
lässt das natürlich sehr nah an sich ran
ja also das ist mein lebt das yahoo
sie heißt null risiko viel privilegien
seiner gestalt business gestellt und das
hat ja viel wert was machen und ehrlich
kultur ist komplett andere bank
vermutlich spielt sie habe meinte 12
die lösung ließe und das ist wirklich
das wirklich die gemeinsame runde wo die
lösung jetzt können die große vision to
study meiner inkubatoren strand sondern
edgaras ich musste diese dass das
verhebt dass ich eher steht ein test
märkten erschließen und lustlosen start
bis groß das heißt natürlich die ganz
große finanzierungsrunde kam das war
dann natürlich schon noch mal eine
andere nummer als wir dann gesagt haben
wir internationalisieren nach
deutschland zehnmal so gross wie die
schweiz nach sehr kurzer zeit das sind
natürlich alles riesen meilensteine die
man die die wir glaube ich auch dass
erst wirklich verarbeiten musste und die
strukturen in so einer clans um in so
einem unternehmen mann ist am anfang zu
zweit auch wenn manchmal zu ziehen dann
ist man 30 50 70 120
das war schon eine sehr sehr große
herausforderung aber eine tolle
herausforderung
[Musik]
auch etwas passiert mit dieser masche
diesen tagen geschafft und das eben
nicht verschrecken und auch die hand
der bedarf ist es sehr schwierig wachse
in risikoarme geschafft und so sein muss
haben wir diese über leid was haben wir
machen digitalisierung wird sichert
wettbewerbs würde sich also wo man eine
gute idee hat andere handel jetzt muss
aber sagen dass das gilt für ist genau
so unser brot ist ein von der credit
suisse uns einzubringen in die
relevanten themen und schauen wie wir
diese ideen der startups für uns
einbinden können in unserer digitalen
offerings was mir also ich anders
gemacht haben ich dass man auf eine sehr
starke britischen der fang gemacht also
dass immer das sind sehr breit dass in
startups
das sind wie sie es das sind berater
dass ein technologie provider
verschiedenster couleur
da sehen dass regulatoren sie dass ein
politiker so das hängt einfach das was
ich interessiert also dass das ökosystem
ich schlage dich sehr sehr breit
ich will einziges im team und den bänken
weg und wenn alle anderen das komplett
anderen eck musste medienbranche sind
physiker materien meinen aber trainieren
im handy fotos der kunstbranche
huntlosen ngo bereichen also wirklich
möglichst so dass man das auch ganz
anders stahlwerke in der lübschen
start-ups selber gemacht wenn also
selber die erfahrung gemacht nicht
grünen idee ich diesen unternehmen ist
der schweizer übliche und internetaffin
zum internet york zum hypothek rein
online digital abschließend 80 und
mähren natürlich ist es klar oder
dies glaubt und umso schöner ist es dass
der 19-jährige so richtig durchgestartet
ist das ist zum flaggschiff
ein produkt und alle dort aus sind wir
auf einmal verarbeiten die digitale
steuerung der prozesse ist doch etwas
aufwendiger wie sich das gemeinden so
von außen einfach darstellt aber es sind
sehr sage ich mal kooperative und
proaktive meetings die dort stattfinden
man sucht lösung die stadt als möchten
unbedingt natürlich es einbringen wir
möchten unbedingt innovativ sein
insofern findet man dann doch über viele
ecken dann die lösung wir mit der
organisation welt vor zwei
geschwindigkeit trainer-manager 3g
geschwindigkeit innerhalb von konzernen
stabilität gewährleistet aber nach
ostern viel effizienter und viel
schneller weiter insbesondere seiner
kindlich unternehmen oder mit anderen
unternehmen ist nicht nur vielen technik
was sind pfeiler wurden in der strecke
macht hat was ich fehler gemacht hat und
dass man versucht die ihr fehler macht
dann hat ein großer vorteil aber nicht
hier stehen die straße wo der
wandlungsprozess tore macht diese
agilität und diese mentalität die die
find extra mitbringen sachen
auszuprobieren schnell zu sein zu lernen
auch neue wege zu gehen weg von
traditionellen das muss ein unternehmen
definitiv in zukunft mitbringen warum
soll ich möchte runde das wird wohl bin
ich besser
ich habe ich für sehr schnelle
mannschaft und ich bin die digitalwelt
agent oder ich mir halt ein halber
schritt fordern was sie und dann die
tiere können was ist neu gestellt was
gefordert wird von jahrhundert und darf
nicht der glaube hat und sind nicht so
schnell geht es war aber schnell die oma
gemacht hat und häufig lustig und es war
nicht sichtbar die bilanz und
erfolgsrechnung glaube ich nicht dass
man die deutsche bank das wird geladen
wurden und dass wir auf so eine
veranstaltung referieren und ist
vorstellen ich glaube dass ich da so
druck machen an der innovation gebracht
diese news robert unbehandelt zu mit ich
glaube dass alle banken die bewegung
sind xavier f verwenden oder meine aber
bankiervereinigung hat eine
expertengruppe finde ich die economy
suisse hätten expertengruppe wird jetzt
experten sagen will experte gruppen
machen wir jetzt konzentrieren aber da
ist ja bis ministerium können wir ich
würde eben stand davon abraten von einer
kannibalisierung zu sprechen es ist
komplementär ist eine weiterentwicklung
von modellen und wer sich nicht ändert
er wird zum schluss das nachsehen haben
das heißt zu lange festzuhalten und
traditionellen geschäftsmodellen ist
sehr gefährlich auf der anderen seite
ist es auch unnötig zu früh diese schon
los zu lassen wir finden das auch muss
spaß machen und dann weiter die usk es
ist die wer dann auch noch hoch und dann
war das jetzt wirklich in summe also
dass dieses beispiels ja aber es geht
dabei spielt am schlusstag spielte sehr
sehr robusten entwicklung
[Musik]
wer wirklich das wird schwerer als ein
feiner finte startups zentren der welt
etablieren und speziell im bereich
vorsichtiger gläubig einen absolut 4 in
tiroler wald liegt im bereich von der
bankenmetropole und tiroler spiel also
dass finanzplatz sollen circa doch gute
rolle spielen
die letzte jahr hat extrem viel verband
konferenz vereint gehe muss ich alles
dem thema winter fördere das schweizer
internationale marco wird das möglichst
haben im regulatoren entsprechenden
druck auswirken und das ist eigentlich
wirklich getrieben ja aus der die sich
dort als mehrere us-marken konzentrieren
um reis also warten wir merken aber auf
die winter klangkraft auf der so
genannte findet landkarte wird kann man
sich annette vorräte auschwitz zu
silvester sich tvo extrem viel tech
startups erzielt es ist extrem vielen
modernen aus der schweiz wie an vielen
anderen orten in der schweiz ist
grundsätzlich sehr gut die range weniger
starke industrie
aber messi noch nie dort wo aber berlin
und london ist firmen die dann über 100
mitarbeiter haben gibt es ja im startup
bereich also spricht firmen die dann
vielleicht erst 12 jahre sind nicht
wahnsinnig viel wenn ich schaue wie
viele solche unternehmen in london oder
in berlin unterwegs sind dann erschrickt
man teilweise sie stellen dann jeden
monat mehr leute ein als hier die firmen
vielleicht dann nach 34 jahren total wie
es in der kleines land oder mehr in den
zellen klicken der markt und die
gewerkschaft die primäres masse
geschafft aber das skalieren mit mit
marktgröße und was uns natürlich jetzt
fehlt insbesondere jetzt auch in diesem
winter bereich dass wir wirklich aus der
schweiz heraus firmen haben die jetzt
nicht nur in der deutschschweiz
erfolgreich sind und dann als nächste
große ambitionen in die romandie gehen
und umgekehrt sondern dass wir wirklich
firmen haben die sagen wir wollen
europa marktführer will marktführer
werden in gewissen bereichen des systems
switzerland ist ein riesen world leader
fehlt
ich verstehe dass man in der schweiz
keine keine industriepolitik historisch
macht das ist fakt das wird mir immer so
gesagt und das ist auch zu akzeptieren
die frage ist einfach die welt dreht
sich weiter und andere standorte machen
industriepolitik für find ick was
wirklich fertigt gedankengut und eine
drift überall auch ruhig es kommt
nämlich der neue welt nehmen muss eco
system also ich allein sondern um ein
eco system mir gemeinsam auf gleicher
augenhöhe und das verhalten und das
möglichst rasch auf damit sie das
schweizer möglich wieder kommt das hier
ist im ausland ganz anders schon über
den titel wie der größere community war
wirklich bissig an neuen neuen ideen
aber das spürt man in jeder spitze nicht
das macht eigentlich betrug oder für die
zusammenarbeit auf recht einfache
wechsel wohl viele gesellschafter
musiker im finanzbereich hindern oder
und da müsste man sie jetzt einfach mal
konsequent als finanzplatz als schweiz
dafür entscheiden
insgesamt machen wir das jetzt aber da
fehlt es an abstimmung es fehlt an
koordination es fehlt an finanziellen
ressourcen man glaubt das ist alles gut
das ist einfach nicht so und auch wenn
man mit mit mit politikern spricht die
meisten verstehen überhaupt nicht was
find ick ist klar einer klar meine ich
also da sind große startup von heute
schweiz würden wichtige beitrag leisten
großmann ich irgendwo 500 millionen bis
eine milliarde irgendwo also in der
größe noch nicht dass man kapital sowie
für gestellt für die jetzt auch genannt
dass sich diese herum
es wäre also größere ticket für
schweizer schweizer start-up industrie
dem einig das geld ist ja der
pensionskasse
eigentlich fällt nur derjenige der
solche strecken war die schlussendliche
so entstand silicon valley ist trotz
erfolgen ich extrem für risikokapital
deutsch verfügbar ist er in einer klasse
ist eine wahnsinnige dynamik können der
züge und mit hatte sich sehr sehr gut
die verluste einzige das man gerade im
windbereich jeder stufe jeder schweizer
bis anschluss konnten aufbauen wenn man
eigentlich eher schon fast alle
handwerker in dieser fabrik hat warum
macht man es nicht es ist für mich und
das was mich am meisten frustriert ist
dass es vergleichsweise wenig geld
bräuchte warum steckt man das nicht in
die jungen leute in die jungen
unternehmer die sich wirklich einen arm
und ein bein rausreißen um diese
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und das ist
für mich eben wenn man nur ein promille
oder was weiß ich wirklich so wenig in
so eine art staatsfonds packen würde für
die schweizer jungunternehmer das ist
mir unerklärlich das verstehe ich nicht
ich glaube dazu gestellt media absolut
chance dass das mandat aufgeben
sicher aber ist klar und wenn ich mal
einfach sehr gut wenn ihre höheren der
schnittstelle zum umgang
innovation immer immer immer geschafft
umfeld kommt aber nicht für ihn
also ja ich habe mir einfach verschnitt
linie ist in paris nahmen aber
grundsätzlich und nicht von innen oder
thema wie crowdfunding oder wie wiebrock
cherry cherry ökonomie
das ist aber nicht die l'équipe
offensichtlich vom tisch wunderbar aber
daran versuchen zu verstehen was haben
mit dem blog schein machen wie ich habe
mir dass sie es geschafft integrieren
wie sieht schnittstelle zu einem anderen
film bringt segen wir bis an der aktion
ist natürlich finanz und nicht
technologie also ich find dich gemäß
definition und ich habe plötzlich
abgrenzt vor der finther szene und ich
habe mich oft gefragt warum das ich und
eine möglichkeit ist dass der patient
ideologisch bitcoin macht oder sonst mit
einer krypta wenig beschäftigt sind
event nicht einfach als tatort macher
zum geld verdienen oder guten
businessplan realisieren sondern die
wende
das finanzsystem revolutionieren es ist
eminent wichtig dass unternehmen gehören
öffnet um ideen anderer geschäftsmodell
anders denken eigentlich die eigene
kultur verschreiben gestartet analyse
der mitarbeiter motiviert in der nhl
reichen
und irgendwann sie mit einem punkt vor
um beschränkt die ihre patente energy
innovation warum beschränken die nummer
aufrufen eigentlich auf die eigene
zweite chance ist es spielt warum nicht
alle android scouting hat man relativ
schnell im griff und alt situation wird
oder man hätte meinen co ltd arrow
großen wert auf schöne tolle ratssaal
unternehmen unternehmen kontaktiert aber
man hätte die partie gehen möchte damit
erschaffen und terrors erforderlich
eigentlich haben wir da die idee luft
gesunde wirtschaftsstandort ist wenn ein
wald wo wenn man krampfhaft versucht die
alte bäume stütze durch nicht nachhaltig
die nachhaltige methode ist zeige ok ab
und zu geht ein alter baum will
alt und schmächtig wird und dafür
wachstum nach und die größte gefahr ist
wenn man verhindert dass die jungen
erwachsenen also wenn man zum beispiel
zu viel regulierung macht sodass fixiert
sind das junge start ups die nicht
freigeräumt
ich denke meine schwester jenna würde
schlicht risiko der vag ist völlig
liegen experimente immer wieder versuche
und etwas gut entwickelt man sich weiter
und zwar zum ziel hat ein ort wo man
alles neu und anders orientieren aber
ein großer sprung
auch wenn sich der bank genug schnell ab
das glaube ich nicht das geschäftsmodell
grundsätzlich bedroht ist was aber die
schwierigkeit ist ein auto mit soll die
technologie arts wende wird innovation
fangt ihr mit tanner
wenn man technologie beherrscht sondern
denen wenn man sich an macht bringt wenn
wir die 10 jahres ist bild 20 26 und
vielleicht kann man das video war was
mir dazu auf erzählten wahrscheinlich
weil mehr den themen halt nicht auf dem
radar hatte ich glaube die spanische
muschel einigungs die rückhand ins out
und ja es ist entwickler und irgendein
wette fakt ist dass man seine mutige
entscheidungen treffen und sagt macht
die tiere ich glaube ich vermute dass
mehrere ec basierend auf der neuen
technologien und der block channel
technologie fundamental verändert haben
und nicht genau abschätzen
insbesondere im internet aktionsgeschäft
also erhöht integrationsleistung sind wo
eigentlich und digital ersetzt weile zu
sagen gerade bei der digitalisierung und
wir genau wo digitale verluste
ich finde aber für forscher untere
bereich vorstellen wie wir die
digitalisierung sei und dass wir
tatsächlich fundamentale veränderungen
und mit gut aber lecker wie das video
zeigt und wie man in zukunft einmal an
sich selber reden viel über möglichkeit
das machen aber es gibt verhältnismäßig
wenn ihr lügt wenn die glut oder
mögliche könnten zeige ich mach setzen
ihre mit ihren einkommen ein schweizer
franken auf den block gehen oder ich
gründe die standesorganisation wo
irgendetwas macht und für das pferd zum
teil an tools also als
softwareentwickler weil ich mit gut die
tools angewiesen die entwicklung
spielten sich halt entwicklungsphase
aber das ist doch jetzt ist dass man das
zum teil bisher geist fällt zum afrika
und mache
es geht toni winter unternehmen in dem
land nicht so viel aber tolle botschaft
hängt mit grossbanken wieder größere
kantonalbanken mit verbund von
regionalbanken substanziell mehr als
generiere und das ist schön spielt
nämlich die traditionelle bank was sie
tun und 150 orten der liste finden
unternehmen häufig kritisch was seit 23
jahren ist in die bude hat aber hat
geschafft weil er sehr fokussiert ist
mal wirklich das problem gelöst sein mit
der bank das wieder entwickler und das
sind die unternehmen und ich sage was
toll ist auch für den block 2 genau aus
dieser große chance für den standort
theorie ist mir die ganze technologische
entwicklung nutzen
im finanzbereich und da auch neue ideen
nicht nachdenken neue idee ja auch eine
etablierte wo der finanzmärkte milieu so
stark sind im kanton zürich weiter
stärken
die orden wie es war wie ein schweizer
zum tanz auf das hat schon normal
aufgewachsen speziell und gehört für das
machen wie schnell zu hoch und sportlich
noch kampfhunde spar eurospar mit drei
für die schnellen fußball
das ist nicht kurz auf singapur und dann
wieder durch new york das eine verlangen
berger und alles über video ist nicht
gleich wenn man sich live als zweitgerät
und know how im land extrem viel weil
das die sie den kindern und struppi
umkreis sondern banken das ist und wenn
mit ruby erste christ die von madness
versucht er bewertet eine blackbox
strategisch wichtig für uns wichtig also
wenn extrem viel toni brennt mit extrem
viel know how ich bin eben vor drei
jahren in die schweiz gekommen ich habe
dann club gegründet ich habe mit den
jungs als er fest gegründet und ich
wurde unglaublich herzlich aufgenommen
und das ist glaube ich nicht
selbstverständlich und das ist auch
etwas was ich der schweiz wirklich sehr
hoch anrechnen
die für investoren von den dingen
interviews ich meine das wollte den film
foundation
because they said
genial bislang für die menschenrechte
wir sind neutral
politisch stabil perfekt für globale
lösung gott der schweiz vertraue war wir
in jeder umfrage regelmäßig machen
banken und versicherungen hemd risikos
wird dieser große frage stelle ist wenn
du von google oder für apple wird ein
barcode in schlechte quelle oder der
etablierten bank zu verstehen und
unisono mit hoch prozent seiner und egal
ob alt oder jung und egal wie shift das
vertrauen in die banken versicherungen
ich heute noch gehen und wald die
größeren schaffen das geschäftsmodell
entwickelt instruktiv ist wo ist der
schweiz geboren ich hoffe ich danken
stützverband kann dank völlig dem
unterstützung von ec hannover endlich
ein staat ist das eine super geschichte
schweiz als acht millionen land hat ein
film technology richtung entwickelt wo
der vor zehn punkten liegt schwärmt die
in london logisch mit klein zicker augen
oft spitzenreiter war mit das beste
marketing und der hand vor
das war genau die block chaim research
hat im kantons etablieren
hoffe das klingt ja wieder als die reine
finanz branche
es betrifft versicherungsbranche es geht
ein neuer branche wo sich entwickler mir
völlig egal
ich kann mir vorstellen wo mütter werden
ich glaube dass es in der schweiz extrem
gute talente hat ich glaube wir auch
gerade von der historie her haben wir im
wissen und unsere reputation die man
unbedingt nutzen muss aus meiner sicht
geht es darum jetzt finance and find ick
zu transformieren also dass man guckt
wie bekommen wir dieses finanzwissen das
noch da ist die leute sind hier noch
wie kriegt man das transformiert in die
in die zukunft in die digitale welt es
die show um das schwitzen dass sie
schauen konnte und syrien die handkasse
erdöl und pumpe aber findet mit
einfachen sogar sollte außerdem die hand
gibt
eishockey talente im sinn für die
innovationskraft und das die 30 sternen
und deine stärken ist immer gut aber
immer wieder in aufbau und die pflege
der hand die chance
ich sehe dass lola spieler auf dem nach
hinten damit der finanzplatz schweiz
stellen
mein wunsch wäre sind mutig werden
unternehmer und unternehmerinnen name 30
und lehnt eine von der gesellschaft und
martina wanner luft noch okay dann hat
man dort mehr gründer das heißt ein
ökosystem entsteht und wenn der gründer
sind dann kommen die investoren und wenn
der gründer und investoren sind dann
kommen vielleicht auch die innovation
lab von den großen unternehmen sie jene
ubs mit dem level hinein in london
und dann entsteht da einfach so einen
strudel den man auch gar nicht mehr
aufhalten
community möglichkeit mit mit
innovationsfreundliche oder freunde
gefunden und partner ganz neues
entwickeln also macht wahnsinnig viel
spaß da vinci mehr oder dass man
wirklich gemeinsam der schweiz wo sie
stehen und der richter eine richtung
mekka system zwischen banken startups
das mache dass ich sexy aber es war die
zusammenarbeit zwischen nichts gegen und
mitten und oder die eigene interesse
2000 und dann sowas braucht transport
nicht wie sie
sein name stellt tops besitz der banken
versicherung sind und damit das stark
treten was nicht sondern miteinander
verbunden diese gemeinsamkeit die die
schweiz hier jetzt zutage trägt ist
einmalig und setze ich auch ab in der
welt das ist sehr sehr positiv aber mal
kooperation siebten start bringen im
optisch also strukturen schafft und
regulatorisches umfeld schafft er das
und dann müssen wir mit einer 15 mit
banken und ex unternehmer trägt politik
thema versuchen das ganze puzzle messi
und der klare was in der schweiz
passiert wird und was für gründe gibt
warum so wichtigen schritt eines datums
und auch nie lernen wie es amerika und
ich aus irgendeinem die engländer machen
marketing betrieben einfach lud sie und
bezog sie mir wir möchten die globale
hauptschiff in technology in die vier
themen das bild was ich mir wünsche
[Musik]